well he is a rock star a businessman a
father and a husband and now you can add
artists to the list i sat down with kiss
frontman gene simmons to talk about his
new shows in las vegas his art show and
a possible kiss residency
gene simmons thank you for sitting down
with me today
show me that snap you got some attitude
in it i have no idea what i'm doing
we are here looking at some of your art
at the palazzo
how long have you been an artist this
was my secret passion all my life
i i'm very sort of
can't figure out what to do with my
hands which is not always a good thing
it
gets you in trouble and so i'm usually
doodling or taking notes and doing
something this pandemic as sad as it was
for the world
and tragic but also gave me a chance to
sort of sequester and
uh went into an industrial park there
was a large space and i ordered canvases
and paint and all this kind of stuff and
see what see what happens and these are
some of your
quote-unquote doodles that i would
hardly call these doodles
i'll put it back to that so that it
doesn't see it because on the back i
never i always use both sides of all the
time because i used to be poor so you
don't want to throw away the paper only
on one side no get out of here so you're
just
sitting around and this is what you come
up and this is so intricate i mean you
were talking about shading and
sometimes sometimes it's just uh
have you got a loose uh
piece of paper and a pen or something
i'll show you what i mean can you just
draw something i'm going to show you how
you're going to draw something and say
wow that's pretty good now without
planning anything
just kind of start doing this
now be
aggressive with it
and then see
see if you see anything
and then create
out of that i'm starting to draw a woman
and of course i drew that
so that's my
dear mom no
no better human being ever walk the face
of the planet tell me about your mom a
little bit
my mother
came from hungary in a very bad time in
human history
and at 14 years of age she was in
concentration camps of nazi germany
and she saw her whole family
destroyed not just murdered but tortured
and starved and all that so and you can
kind of see the the sadness in her eyes
he really captured even when she smiled
there's some
some sad thing and yet she had a
sort of an uplifting point of view about
humanity she actually thought that
humanity was
by and large good she was a much better
human being than i would ever be she
actually believed in the goodness of
mankind and this
is me at about five
i have to ask you before i let you go
is the kiss residency coming to las
vegas we are my favorite band who wears
more makeup and higher heels than you of
a war
are gonna be at uh
where are we gonna be
actually no it's zappos
god bless you
in las vegas starting december 27th
that's right even through new year's and
we'll be here through
uh february but in the middle of the
kiss tour that's going around the world
and i hear you're a new las vegas
resident i am welcome to las vegas thank
you i just bought it
you want to come over for dinner tonight
stop it you're a married woman
i meant for my husband my husband's a
huge fan i don't know what he was
assuming there i love his instructions
on how to doodle i think gene simmons is
the next bob ross he he's so talented
his artwork just all around was
absolutely gorgeous so it's going to be
quite the show it's happening in october
you can go down there and he's going to
be there and where is it taking place
it's happening at the grand canal shops
no it's a residency oh the residents
here at the zappos god bless you
all right time to take